depuis le départ j'ai indiqué que les
municipales ça devait pas être un choix
politique
ça devait simplement être un choix
sanitaires pour la santé des français
ou bien c'est possible et en os x est
vraiment possible et pour l'instant le
comité scientifique est extrêmement
prudent si c'est possible
vraiment avec le deuxième rapport il ne
dit pas que c'est impossible non il dit
qu'il va y avoir un deuxième rapport
attendant deuxième rapport et si c'est
possible on le fait si ce n'est pas
possible on prend le temps et surtout on
ne fait pas courir de risques aux
français mais six et quinze jours
seulement avant le 28 juin ce qui est
prévu pour l'instant ça laisse très peu
de temps peut-être pour faire campagne
pour les candidats vous comprenez les
difficultés que ça soulève
non mais dans tous les cas une campagne
pour un second tour ses huit jours entre
un premier et un second tour celle des
chinois donc le fait qu'ils aient quinze
jours non le fait est que
vraisemblablement que cette campagne là
même si elle dure un peu plus longtemps
sera très contrainte en matière de
rassemblement parce que il y à la
distanciation sociale et ça on ne peut
pas mésestimer le risque avec par
exemple des rassemblements qui devront
sans doute être interdite il faudra
faire une autre forme de campagne est ce
que vous estimez que l'exécutif qui
reçoit les chefs de partis tout à
l'heure cherche à faire porter le
chapeau aux oppositions sur ce sujet ne
lui aviez pas vous justement reproché de
ne pas avoir clairement consulter des
battu au premier tour à dans
l'ajustement l'a fait justement il nous
avait consultés au premier tour et il
nous avait indiqué d'ailleurs qui avait
pas de problème on était au stade 2 de
l'épidémie ça avait duré 10 minutes sur
une réunion qui avait elle même duré
plus de plus de deux heures
et puis c'était le jeudi et puis tout à
coup précipitamment le premier ministre
vient la veille à 19h30 devant les
caméras de télévision
dire que on passe au stade 3 d'épidémie
et qu' il boucle tous les lieux publics
et que le scrutin aura quand même minute
avait changé l'ordre ont ensuite échangé
donc et en plus on a essayé ensuite de
mettre sur le dos d'opposition cette
décision qui ne relevaient pas
d'ailleurs des oppositions mais bien du
président république et du premier
ministre
donc voilà nous on a voté d'ailleurs ici
au sénat comme à l'assemblée nationale à
une très large la région
une loi c'est toi dit quoi et 10 k le
rapport du comité scientifique
il ya un conseil des ministres et que
c'est désormais au premier ministre au
gouvernement de trancher cette loi
d'ailleurs avait prévu le deuxième tour
à la fin du mois de juin si bien sûr si
les conditions sanitaires étaient réunis